Resuelve para "x" y para "y".
Y aquí tenemos un par de ecuaciones,
"-3x" más "4x" igual a 11,
"y" más "2x" igual a 13,
y bueno, quiero resolver este par de ecuaciones
por el método de eliminación
o de suma y resta,
sin embargo lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta es que si yo sumo el lado izquierdo de esta ecuación,
voy a obtener algo que tiene que ver con "y",
las "y" no se van a cancelar,
voy a obtener algo que tiene que ver con "x",
las "x" tampoco se van a cancelar
y por lo tanto no tengo ninguna de
las dos variables que se cancelen.
Entonces para aplicar el método de suma y resta,
lo que voy a hacer es
escalar una de estas dos ecuaciones
y para escalar una de estas dos ecuaciones,
date cuenta que si yo tuviera aquí abajo un "3y" entonces podría cancelar la "y",
por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar toda esta ecuación, la ecuación de abajo por 3,
de tal manera que aquí me queda un "3y"
para que yo pueda cancelar la "y"
con la ecuación da arriba y si multiplico todo esto
por 3 me queda 3 por "y", "3y", 3 por "2x"
es lo mismo que "6x" y esto es igual a 13 por 3,
13 por 3 es 39.
Hay que multiplicar por 3 ambos lados de la
ecuación, no se te olvide,
todo lo multiplicamos por 3 y realmente lo que estoy haciendo es escalando esta ecuación
y por lo tanto mi información se conserva,
estas dos ecuaciones me están diciendo lo mismo
y bueno, aquí arriba voy a poner la primera ecuación que
es "-3x" más "4x" igual a 11
y ahora date cuenta, ya voy a poder
eliminar la variable "y", "-3y" más "3y"
se van a cancelar y por lo tanto, algo muy padre va a pasar así que vamos a hacerlo,
"-3y" más 3y, estos dos se cancelan, se van y después me queda "4x" más "6x" es lo mismo que "10x"
y del otro lado me queda 11 más 39,
lo cual es 50
y ahora, si yo divido entre 10
ambos lados de la ecuación,
lo que me va a quedar es que "x" es igual a 50 entre 10,  lo cual es lo mismo que 5,
"x" igual a 5 es parte de la solución
de este sistema de ecuaciones.
Ahora lo que tengo que hacer es obtener el
valor de "y" sustituyendo el valor de "x"
en una de esas dos ecuaciones y voy a utilizar
la de abajo y me queda, "y" más "2x",
pero "x" vale 5, "y" más 2 por 5, estoy tiene
que ser igual a 13, y bueno, 2 por 5 es 10,
entonces me queda que "y" más 10 es igual a 13
y si yo resto 10 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
lo que voy a obtener es que "y"
es lo mismo que 3, "y" va a ser igual,
estos dos se cancelan y 13 menos 10 es 3.
Perfecto, ya tengo que "x" igual a 5, "y" igual a 3,
es la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones,
ahora con este par de valores vamos a intentar comprobar que realmente sean la solución.
Por lo tanto vamos a sustituir el valor de
"x" y el de "y" en ambas ecuaciones y me queda,
-3 por "y", es decir, -3 por 3 más 4 por "x",
es decir, más 4 por 5,
esto tiene que ser igual a 11,
¿y qué me queda?
-9 más 20 es igual a 11, perfecto,
ésta si se cumple.
Y en la otra me queda que "y" más "2x" es
igual a 13, es decir que 3, más 2 por 5,
esto tiene que ser igual a 3,
lo cual, pues si es cierto,
esto es igual a 13
y también se cumple esta otra ecuación,
por lo tanto estos dos valores,
"x" igual a 5 y "y" igual a 3,
son la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones.
Ahora bien, también había otra forma de
pensar este mismo problema,
déjame copiar la primera ecuación que tengo aquí,
"-3y" más "4x" igual a 11
y ahora imagínate que lo que quisiéramos es eliminar en una primer instancia a la "x"
y por lo tanto lo que necesito es que este "2x"
se convierta en un "-4x"
y para eso lo que necesito hacer es multiplicar toda la ecuación de abajo por -2,
escalar la ecuación de abajo por -2
y recuerda que la información se conserva,
¿y qué me quedaría?
"-2y" menos "4x" es lo mismo que 13 por -2,
lo cual es -26 y ahora si sumo estas dos ecuaciones,
estos dos se van, aquí me queda "-5y"...
"-5y" y esto es igual a 11 menos 26,
lo cual es -15 y ahora si yo divido ambos lados de
la ecuación entre -5, ¿qué me va a quedar?
Que "y" es igual a -15 entre -5,
lo cual es 3,
¿y qué crees?
llegamos a la misma respuesta, ya con este valor de 3, podríamos sustituir este valor de 3
en alguna de estas dos ecuaciones para
obtener el valor de "x",
pero date cuenta de que todas maneras
llegaríamos a que "x" es igual a 5.
¡Perfecto!
esto quiere decir que en un principio si buscamos eliminar la "x" en lugar de eliminar la "y"
llegamos a la misma respuesta.
Y con esto obtenemos dos formas distintas de resolver el mismo sistema de ecuaciones
por el mismo método,
nos vemos en el siguiente video.